already
hey hello hello everyone and
uh let me just check if everything is
working
i haven't been uh firing up the stream
for a while but yeah it seems like
it's working it's green and the audio
seems to be here
uh just click something or or write
something if if everything is
uh operational should be it's uh it's a
little bit uh warm over here
uh but it's summer so i guess that's uh
that's normal
uh yeah okay so people seem to be
joining in so
here we're we're about to have a nice
tournament it's called the
uh the what's the tournament called a
king of the castle
and this here you can only see half of
his face is the organizer of the
tournament
uh so while i go get something goran
will tell you a little bit about
this about this tournament uh and then
we're diving straight into it
let me just check how many people are
here okay already 21 people
it's a close tournament uh but um you
have to qualify to play in this one so
it's a
it's a pretty big deal we're gonna play
the tournament and then afterwards we're
gonna we're gonna be accepting some
challenges uh all right
a few words about about the tournament
the tournament
king of castle is planned eight
tournaments
and only three places goes to the final
that was 24 players and after that we
will
have one tournament 12
hours played and we have three players
also qualified that was 27 players
and two whip guests ivanesco and ivano
will play maybe and today we played one
tournament extra tournament for the
30th place okay nine players cannot play
we have no changes and we will today
have
uh the king of the castle and he will
play the final tournament against
uh the qualifier the next month i think
we will have again eight tournaments and
then we will have 24 players
and uh so will it be every month every
month uh
will be one-on-one for the little
king of castle yeah and after 24
we have again final tournament for one
qualifier
and this will this player will play then
one
on one again the king of castle and
this will be 12 matches
uh four games one bullet
uh three minutes blitz game and three
plus zero
uh three plus uh two seconds increment
yeah okay but for this one uh
a lot of people are asking if this is a
close tournament yes this one is closed
since
you had to qualify to play in the world
players are qualified for this
tournament
no one can play this tournament but you
can play the qualified tournaments
yeah they will start from tuesday
they'll play
tuesday fridays and saturdays every
tuesday every friday and every saturday
we will have a tournament eight one and
then we have the final
battle tournament for the qualifier and
after that
he will play one-on-one match against
the king of castle
and today we will yeah and for the
moment we don't have
any prizes but uh we do have some but we
will not
disclose them as of yet but it it will
be a great honor to be
king of the castle the first one
yeah someone says it's a cronullino's
father yes uh uh
but your full house is not playing in
this one
okay jose is my brother yeah rich james
abelda okay all right
uh filipino is my son evanesca is also
my son
so almost uh half of the tournament is
family
not really but uh all right so there are
four minutes uh
until the start of the tournament uh i'm
gonna i'm gonna invite
some people another invite to greet some
people in the chat you can play uh
you you have enough time for a bullet
game if you want
okay all right let's let's do it here uh
you you will be playing under my handle
so we're gonna play an unrated game
all right there you go enjoy okay
let's play here i have to look
i thought i uh i'm not gonna have to
install air conditioning here but
uh it it seems it was a pretty pretty
big blunder
hey bru what's up man uh yeah this is
one tournament that you will not be able
to join uh this is a close tournament uh
you
people have to qualify to play in this
one uh
goran here is is the organizer and uh
so far like he said eight tournaments
have been played and the winner of this
tournament will be
uh the first king of the castle and uh
later on he will have he will have
challenges from other
uh players who who will attempt to be
also king of the castle
okay
who did i vote for
sorry to hear about your cat i i really
love
cats it's a it's a it's a it's a
terrible thing
when such something like that happens
why why is ted bundy in the top right
okay let's go here uh
that that's only here for the moment if
we have some guests
that are not here in my house that
sometimes join i think so far we've had
like two
then they take the the place of misha
here
from the hospital
but
[Laughter]
if you want
yeah i think i think everyone knows that
style in the in the upper right yeah
when is nepal versus carlson apple
versus carlson is in in november in
dubai
oh 2500 what is this oh it's not 25 it's
25 question mark
[Music]
okay let's go for my standard bullet
what is what is the marion
is it the marian chess i've never heard
of that actually no it's not my dad
that's that's mikael
ah you would you want me to to do like a
house tour okay
i i could do that for i can't do it now
since the the live stream camera doesn't
uh doesn't go around the house
uh but i could record some of them
uh you you you cannot have the password
for the tournament this is a private
tournament that
uh to decide the the king of the castle
the first ever king of the castle
yes yes tal is my dad well well said
thank you mr randy diaz thank you it's
uh
it's a it is quite the baby
who is the bald guy next to me that is
that is even lubitsch here
yes
oh there we go oh
nicely done all right so here we go
of course i can speak creation oh we're
not we're not go oh you also can join
no no i will not join we're not trying
i'll just uh get rid of these guys okay
ivano is also playing
eight years old with guests
i'm gonna play pt web
you cannot play okay let's just uh start
with this one
so uh richie james abelda
was the first today he's the top seed of
the tournament yeah
the first playing against the mizell 10.
all right so these are three minutes
zero seconds increment yeah yes yes all
right night
night runs swiss tournament
and samir i i only read
the first book of harry potter i i did
not read the
the other ones but i i enjoyed the first
one very much
what is this what is what
what is the meaning of eta
there is no meaning it's a name yeah
it's a name
[Laughter]
do i have any more rasheed games uh
there are there are
uh surely a lot of good ones but um
i i've covered like uh maybe 10 or 15 so
far
cena what is this the what i don't
understand yes yeah youngeta is fully
operational
andrea pozzer
it means something in spain and it's not
good it's uh well it's a good thing
we're not in spain then
who is your favorite chess player i
don't know
oh yeah oh oh he missed a nice one oh no
he didn't no he didn't
we'll see mazel 10 is very strong
i played against him many games i think
no this is not
this is not the friend that brought beer
no no no
that friend was still not in any of the
streams
will i cover geary's game in gran
chester i was just about to cover it and
then i remembered that we
we had this tournament planned but i
will cover it yeah it's uh
pretty crazy and it's uh
well it's remarkable how he was able to
get out of that one
the password is secret yeah yeah but not
secrets to enter the
you can't enter this one
my favorite chess player is obviously
karpov
i like karpov
all right this will be interesting game
deceivia thanks man thanks a lot
francis
yes karpov is for me the best
chess player what do you think goran
will magnets retain uh will magnus keep
his title
uh yeah i think this time
[Music]
he'll be again first the winner but the
next time i think
he will lose the title
okay they are they're really really
trying their best here
yes the title is the king it's a
uh it's a one-hour tournament uh nine
nine rounds
uh six minutes ah it's a swiss swiss
tournament
you can play only yeah it's better than
making it an arena no
you play against stronger player when
you win you play
against the player who has the same
points of
tournament and that's why it is
interesting
okay uh you can talk a little louder
okay okay
i don't i don't know if people hear you
yes
yeah okay nipple might be a little bit
inconsistent
from time to time but not really i mean
he's uh
if you if you if you check how how high
rated he is
and now he will be the most prepared
that he ever was
in his life i imagine so i don't think
that's that's going to be an issue
thank you games lady my life
to him who me
now it's time trouble
the rook yes
very good no maybe sacrifice yeah
no he just couldn't he could take no he
couldn't
and the queen later no yeah i thought he
was maybe checkmate
no it is no
[Music]
it will be a drawish game but okay
yeah i think that i think there was
something in there
he's a pissed down but better with time
this is not fair yeah it's uh it's a bit
harsh to say that creativity is dead in
modern chess
i think that uh nowadays who who is able
to use
engines uh to to be creative i think
that's also that's also uh
you know
a version of creativity i i would say
okay this is time
lost thank
johnny thank you we love you too johnny
okay
let's go back okay so he lost
just uh no just x here x no no
yeah x and that's it okay yeah
everything you
won a game car spy also won again yeah
who else is anyone still playing oh no
next round is in 20 seconds
what is happening with my brother my you
lost the game oh man
to who i don't know the phillip no i
think not
he lost the game borna poster borna
what do i think about chess 960 it's uh
well it's very very enjoyable but it can
also be uh
a little bit boring all depends on what
kind of a position you get okay
let's look here but all in all yeah
i mean it's uh it's great my son
filipino all right
versus philippines
very interesting line this is gonna be
this is gonna be super sharp
e4 yes why why players don't play the
evans gambit in higher tournaments
well they do they just use the the dub
of events
yes the modern yeah with
c3 and then b4
why are your videos adjectives
i i have no idea why don't you
yeah but it's like people who like chess
you know they they see one thing then
they want to see another one
uh immediately i think it's like that
with with all the chess
like you know if you have like problems
you want to solve you start with one and
then
you you can't stop
very good picture is out of focus
i don't i don't think that that's
possible since it's uh
it's an autofocus camera it should auto
focus right away
unless it's unless it's a silly camera
and it focuses on the microphone
i played today two classical games
against my sons i draw both games yeah
there's
there's a our chess club championship in
classical
uh happening at the moment goran how is
it going
oh very bad for me today i have two
draws against my sons uh
filipino is very good oh he can grab the
rook
no queen captures rook
okay but then maybe yes of course
this is better but then pawn capture
nice nice tricky tricky
will enviable win the candidates one day
well if
he didn't do it now it's it's very hard
to say
uh i don't know i don't know what chess
books to recommend for today because
today you have so many now take the
bishop
so many different uh resources online
and everything but
uh you know i imagine the classics are
still
as good as they were
uh like i i don't think you you you will
ever ever be able
to replace like doritos end game manual
or or you know books like that
[Music]
can he take now the pawn
why he don't there is no password to the
tournament since this is a close
tournament for
for people who have qualified
uh 500 master games of chess yeah
it'd be very interesting to go through
that i i don't know which
which games it uh
uh it it holds uh if tartakover wrote it
i imagine though those are very very old
oh no or what he blundered
did he give him check okay now he can
take
the queen no it's good
yeah it's okay now i think he's
would ah no at the pawn
what why did he not take the pawn
on f4 maybe
oh very interesting very good my son
he's better on time okay and now
rook can't very
yeah but down upon this
look no no
oh no what he could play yeah
he could play rook oh he had it he had
it
oh my goodness what's he done
uh this is my dave a day westerner this
is my brother-in-law he's the organizer
of the tournament
uh for those of you who are still trying
to join this is a close one yeah
nice idea yeah uh but after this
tournament is over we
will play some games yes of course
very interesting how he's doing
he's playing on time i see okay
now can take
he have to take
and again
hey mr heinz thank you
in time trouble yes chronoldino is is a
monster
no monster good day mr asian not asian
have a nice one okay now
it's time to
[Music]
very interesting
yeah i don't think he can do it he can
maybe win on time but
not oh
no it's okay yeah i don't think it is
i think it's okay
no yes yeah no that
that's that's lost how lost well he's up
upon he's uh in time
look what he's had no loss for white i
mean for right here yeah
this is okay now
he was he managed to pull it off no we
should be four
okay he will play on time of course
now very good yes
yeah that's it that's it
okay very cool very cool
he will play on time of course oh jess
he has to be careful not to repeat the
position three oh
very good okay he won nice
nice one 24 or 24 oh my goodness
yeah all right we have two more games
going on
uh yazar of still playing like against
let's see that one
oh it's uh it's a flag off all right uh
oyozaro is trying to flag him but
okay now it's a troll or maybe he wins
he he can still win if he if he's not on
a phone
if he's able to pre-move it he can win
will he do it no it's a draw it's a draw
keep flagging him move on the game
no one it's a draw no zero
001
because uh i don't know ah maybe in
swiss
the rules are different no who is black
yeah that's really weird let's check
[Music]
no but usarov did not win
[Music]
okay very interesting this way
very interesting okay all right so who
do we have next
copai crossbar crossbar the first copper
class by
okay it's a nice struggle what's this
playing what do we have here
oh okay okay super super symmetrical
for nice variation let's go crossbay
uh yeah i thought i thought that this
one might be an event gambit but
uh seems like it wasn't yeah yazaru was
black in that one
yes that was the idea
how you doing man b4
your predictions for euro 2020 that's uh
what
football yeah that plays last year i
have 20 21
yeah i mean maybe they still call it
maybe it was uh
this witness played last year because of
this pandemia
oh maybe yeah that's fine yeah i know i
know it was supposed to be
what is agath nickname a gp thanks for
the donation man
i will buy my daughter a pair of tartan
socks you are scottish
all right play do arista we will play
evans gambit
tournament i will organize one evans
gambit tournament
and you can only play in anyone's gambit
for i will
remove this yes and we will play this
uh who will this game this tournament he
will qualify for the fight yeah
yeah we have to make uh we have to also
make an eta invitational
yeah wait i don't know next week maybe
next oh no uh next next year
like for for for first birthday maybe
okay
no not not next week
no this this is not my son no no
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm told be son brother-in-law yes
yeah i've seen i've seen levy's rap
video it's it's really awesome
it's a really it's a great one
i like the the the the video and the
lyrics
i i'm not a big fan of autotune i i
prefer
you know if autotune wasn't used but
other than that it's it's really
really a nice one
yeah they grow up so fast yeah
we not greetings vinod
when can we see a guy's a gm oh
it will it will be one year in one year
maybe a maybe an honorary one but
uh a real one i don't know
will i will i make a wrap for all time
sick perhaps perhaps
it is not it is not out of the question
yes this is this is mr liu butch yes
maybe
can i comment on my game against magnus
oh i already made a video on it that was
that was uh
like a year ago or maybe a year and a
half ago
and for those of you who are interested
when the morphe saga will resume
uh i always say this uh i i started the
sagas when
uh there still wasn't all that much
chess in the world there was like a
classical tournament and then there was
nothing for like a month and a half and
i
i i needed to create some something
while nothing was happening in the world
but now with so much stuff happening in
the world i still basically use the
sagas as
something that i do in between
tournaments so now one tournament uh
just ended and now we have immediately
the other one the
classical tournament in bukharesh that
that was uh
uh that started today so i will be
covering some of the games from that
tournament
and if for example nothing interesting
happens in that one day then i will uh
use this opportunity to also return to
the morphe saga
but yeah i know it's been going on for
quite a while now but
uh my my point my my uh wish is to
complete it
at some point not uh not just complete
it
as soon as possible will we go
to the tournament here in croatia in
july the what granchester
i if there will be one probably oh
that's ice in july
yes yeah probably one month yeah
probably we will go shirley
crossbar he will win maybe on time but
oh can he yeah he can't oh no
rook c two is g f two is very difficult
to
angle but not knight knight g6
yes it's the only thing but then move
the knight
and then what's tempo
[Music]
if he didn't have the bishop that was
good but he will play in time of course
yeah on time he can still win
and especially if he will take this much
to
no no no no no he will take it no
what yeah he went under it
okay interesting interesting the king is
coming very interesting
yes two seconds he's playing yeah now
he's just okay
oh no we want to take 20 minutes yeah
like for an arena it's not another
problem yeah
okay let's see what is happening
filipino is still playing
all right yeah but when it happens in a
swiss event
that's okay what was that oh flagging
oh
all right
okay
[Music]
he flagged him oh not good not good rich
james to the flag
no no no sorry no no sorry
i do it the same you have to do the
the right click one where is the
where's the where's our link community
in the community
teams teams and castle
castle
[Music]
okay what is with
uh house of leaves
all right let's let's continue with with
the leader
the top gamers yeah and then after they
finish we can we can do the other guys
it is the name
yes now
someone said that you look like jeff
bezos andre agassi maybe
that they say andragas yeah agassi is
like uh
like also pretty much like like jeff
bezos i
i i i would say
what is crosby doing all right okay
richard james is i think very strong
he's leading he win all games
yes three or three
is evil playing as well esco no yes of
course
i drew a game against him
[Music]
my favorite opening after the evans
gambit is the delayed evans gambit
the night of maybe alzberg
ah to play white against neither oh yeah
this is the best yeah for you
[Music]
start playing different openings no that
that is a big no
he is the he's the only one that still
uh
tries to keep it uh you know as it
should be
he he plays it like bobby fischer played
it
all right so here he had to defend the
e6
now he's in temperatures very very very
strong strong moves
best of the evans gambit
opening books who is chinese
enjoying samurai oh it's too too warm
for rakia here
it's uh it was like raining every day
and it was like
15 degrees celsius and now it's 27 all
of a sudden
yes white is better i think here better
with time
and the black has no moves he's very
passive of course
this is the problem he should he should
walk the king over to the queen side
yeah f5 no he has to he has to block g6
yes but after and then once
you lose the game we'll see we'll see
how the master does it
hey for uh for the moment you can't uh
for the moment you can't
join the tournament as it's a closed one
uh for those of you who still don't know
uh but after this tournament yeah after
this tournament we
we we can play some games and then
my sons will come also here and then
they play against you yeah
yeah they're always streaming i think
yeah zaro is streaming uh
at his own place this is
why he's losing look here
sacrifice of bishop very cool
nice nice nice nice
this is wonderful
okay it's not checkmate now no it is a
problem
yeah yeah now you have a problem
what to do now no you can play bishop e6
and then d5
okay yes this is cool
and you you still win but after will he
see it
above after bishop d four
d5 what's
that
oh very interesting huh
then we you are losing at queen no
then c4 you cannot play c4
f
[Music]
no i thought you could maybe play c4d5
this was
completely
yeah it's being low on time yes but
totally missing
my mortal game is the one game i still
haven't shown no
no no no no i i have one against the
feeder master
two two against two feeder masters but i
know the feeder masters
what i know them yes even from copeland
maybe yeah huh one yes one no
i think i know the game
second league or no no secondly no no
this is
yeah he will flag him he will flag him
right spice
flagging all players
check attack queen me
moved oh that's it he wins he wins
no no yeah yes he wins oh
he has a rook yes but time travel no
no it doesn't matter that's enough time
i can win this
he's winning but he why why is he
playing it like that
pre-move to a queen and just real queen
rook this is draw crossbar is
uh removing all
uh i thought let's watch this yeah he's
probably on his cell phone maybe
if he's not on the smartphone then this
can be
yeah because he had a rook on c5 then
you push the pawn and it's mate in three
but he blundered to queen
yeah but it's okay it's okay
all right so let's use the standings
uh oh next round already starting very
nice
filipino two and a half user of two and
half
[Music]
all right let's naminator watching
naminator nominator nominator is
a friend from my father us from bad
pyramid
he's very strong he's very strong he
qualified today
through the last tournament
so richie is no longer on 100
yes that's uh i don't know
how how he didn't win that one it's
pretty crazy
yes but i think that's when spike could
run when you play good chess but you
don't
don't play enough bullet that is tempo
three plus zero
difficult to play
if it's a really good game uh just send
it to to my email
using hashtag suggestion i will i will
take a look at it
my favorite indian chess prodigy
i don't think it's har it's hard to say
but
probably prague probably prague
if he's still considered a prodigy
because he's now really really strong
uh and rating do you know any of these
players personally
this is all my family yeah
he knows all of them personally yeah i
know most of them
it was a free rook is this the mailman
uh no but he does wear a similar uniform
try and guess what he does the same
deserve this
yeah he's he's with the chess police
is the knight of defense obsolete no no
of course not
naminator is playing very aggressive
will i cover bogdan versus anish yes i
was i was just about to cover it today
and i forgot we had this stream planned
out but
uh uh yeah i will cover it
it was a really short game and uh well
uh uh it's i i don't know
i think since he was playing against
such a strong opponent like anish that
he wasn't even expecting that
there was the the there was that uh
crazy move
but uh yeah it's definitely not an easy
one to see
if he saw it then it's completely
winning even though black did have a lot
of pawns
but yeah i think it wouldn't be a
problem
do i like playing the rat no not
not really my thing look the game no
look the game the knight e6
oh my goodness very good nominator
and now he takes the bishop maybe
i still like black i still like black
yes yes
he just has to push e3 and that's it f4
maybe
and d3 he has the three the light square
bishop but first
f4 now the rook maybe rook g8
you cannot play
rook anywhere yeah okay this is okay
and now now he can see now
yes now he can take
and after he goes yeah f4
no no it's not good yeah now now white
is very happy
look this uh sacrifice what is this man
patrick yeah i i will cover that game no
worries
pendrive is uh pendrive is a gift from
my dad
if you're referring to the to the to
this one
yes the king yeah of course
yeah it's a christmas gift
hey look what's here no he could take
oh my goodness what is he could take on
e8
thoughts on chess gambling what what is
chess gambling
is that like playing chess for money or
or just again or just betting on chess
games
yeah i know i know i know i i i know
i know bogdan missed it i didn't know
anish missed it as well
i i me i thought maybe anish saw it and
then it was the only thing he had
uh i don't know uh i haven't covered
nigel versus udit 1994.
i've covered some of you it's 1994 games
all right so here again time travels but
yeah i i think every game is decided on
time trouble
take yes no queen take it is checkmate
look
queen take and queen g5 checkmate
come
[Music]
and checkmate how he wants to wait for
one second you think yeah
oh come on play yeah okay i thought he
was gonna
wait for one second and i mean after
congratulations congratulations
very good who is the most annoying
grandmaster what do you mean annoying
like
like annoying in
[Music]
in giving interviews or annoying in
playing the most annoying chess
yeah okay
filipino yes you have to open games with
the middle click not with the left one
with the middle
try it try try it then it opens a new
window yeah
okay let's look you there okay maybe
or even esco is playing against okay
let's look here eight eight years old
ivano eight years old
from shibunik let's look this game okay
very very quick he's very fast yes
he plays chess i think one year one
one year and three months i meant you
meant the most defensive player
okay okay most defensive i i guess
someone asked who is the most annoying
grandmaster defense defense player
who plays defense
[Music]
is an attacker a wild attacker he played
this
stein's defense very passive and later
aggressive
yeah maybe
carpool yeah control with left click
also works
yeah i i wanted to keep it simple
this always question what what is two
nine nine two hashtag two nine and two
that's uh that's a great great mystery
secret yeah that will be on
10 million subs yeah oh it's hard to say
if if we'll still be here yes of course
[Music]
please fix it we cannot see the names of
the players what is happening
ah you can't see the names of the
players oh that's
that's a bit weird let me let me just
check
maybe after that i click this
no that's cool ah that's why
okay no no that's something i was fixing
and then it seems like i didn't fix it
but i messed it up
there you go okay now i think it's good
yeah i think this will work
is it now okay yeah i think so yeah i
okay
i grabbed a little bit of the board so
let me just
fix that as well
there we go and a little bit of this one
okay i think should be perfect now
i guess what i think
it's this pranav thank you thanks for
the contribution of gupta
thanks thanks a lot man
uh will i cover nihua versus
levon from 2001 i am not i do not know
this game
i will check it out
ah who is the most stubborn grandmaster
that's what you thought
aren't they all i mean no no one just
reside resigns nowadays
i i really enjoy i really enjoyed
gotham's
gotham's rap everything about it is is
great he he put a lot of work into it uh
i'm like i said i'm not a fan of uh of
autotune but other than that it's really
really very nicely done
nicely nicely executed
how much delay does the chat have i
i think like 10 seconds no it's it's ha
maybe 15 maybe 15 yeah
[Music]
yeah ivano is nine years old yes
eight eight years old eight eight okay
this year is
he will be nine in in process in uh
such an aggressive player yes he is
training with the
gm every day five hundred five hours
next year we're all done for narayan
ramesh thanks for the contribution man
yes ma'am is sleeping peacefully as he
usually does
but yeah but he's here you can't see him
lift
yeah the dog is here
i can uh make a picture
yeah let me show you the how meadow is
chilling
nicely
all right there we go now we will see
this
all right there we go see how mado is
nicely chilling on the floor
king bombs thanks for the contribution
man let me just
uh okay it'll take me a few seconds to
check to
fix the delay but yeah all right there
we have it
okay sorry i'm going up instead of down
the the weird
mirror thing is
there we go this is a draw maybe
all right there we go see
it's like he's dead only he's not
very interesting game
no it is completely lost yes no meadow
has a bed he has he has like three beds
but it's
uh summer here it's it's very warm so uh
he
sometimes he prefers just the floor
sometimes i prefer the floor as well
[ __ ] you know it's completely lost game
[Music]
meadow is meadow is a no breed middle
are you dead
no no no he's very much alive okay
uh ivano loses yeah all right it was a
pretty pretty crazy one
very jewish but okay all right next
round in 24 and the
copa is leading from france where is
your rosaro
i actually played against him one yeah
two times one one no no i haven't i
haven't
nominated
they're all playing these tournaments
they're very okay so 21 players
yes still all right
aren't there haven't two of them already
played no no cross pie
do you think configure spy this one you
want
no no you can watch what you mean
you can watch all right let's go let's
let's check out evanescence
very strong what is the what is he doing
okay that's a very very solid stuff
do i still listen to eminem no not for
some 20 years
uh yeah yeah it's been 20 years
since i've since i've stopped pretty
much
19.
what is this
have you ever tried to teach me the
chess every day
[Music]
what do i think about magnus winning the
ftx crypto cup
what is there to think about it uh he he
played really well and he won
he struggled a little bit in the first
part to actually qualify but
then after getting to the main event it
was pretty pretty straightforward
no i i don't think there will ever be a
sequel to chess
like it will become more dynamic more
active the time control will be
will be getting shorter and shorter and
you know
we want it might get a bit more dynamic
this way
but i i don't think we'll be seeing new
rules
maybe they will play bullet games yeah
like maybe for fun maybe some
chess 960 bullet but
raja
[Music]
what do i expect from magnus and nepo in
dubai i expect uh uh an epic showing
it's gonna it will be yeah drawish again
i have six maybe yeah but now it's 16
games okay
you think not something i don't know i
think every
will win two games because they they say
uh
kayaking versus magnus was a bit of a
snooze fest then
fabi vs magnus was really intense but it
was
it wasn't uh so so intense uh as much as
it was
intense engine prep it's always engine
prep of course but uh
uh other than that one game where fabi
really surprised magnus
uh i don't think it was uh like magnus
was winning
in the first game and then fabi really
uh
surprised magnus with with uh with that
rook to d8 move
uh i i don't know maybe it was game four
or game six
uh but yeah maybe it was a again a bit
of a snooze festival i i'm expecting
nipple versus magnus to be
uh a bit more exciting
uh in a way that maybe like like maybe
maybe if magnus will get a little bit of
a better position and then nipple will
be close to lost
but he's gonna save the game because
that's how nipple rolls
uh he's the only one that can save games
like that so
maybe something like that who knows
let's see how
playing when's the next alpha zero video
when
when they release some more games for
the moment they're using alpha zero for
for other things not not for chess
engine chess
is cool yeah engine chess is cool but
it's not alpha zero chess
but yeah yeah once you get used to
engine games it's it's
uh a little bit hard to watch human
games
yesterday
oh i don't know i i think uh lekko is a
very honorable
gentleman and i think he uh he will do
his best
to to do his job but i don't think he
has like a hidden motive or anything
and i i i don't know still if if he was
leco against magnus
i still wouldn't know what would happen
i mean
lekko is such a such a strong player
that it's hard to hard to say
strongest creation player in your
opinion we have the next week
the next friday at the tournament
against sasha martinovic and he's
actually the uh he's the current
reigning champion of croatia we will
play against him you can find the link
in this agatha mata's castle
when is it friday friday 8 00
pm we will play against him
oh yeah okay magnus versus anand but
that's 2013 and 2014 that's uh
in my opinion at least uh was was more
exciting than
magnus versus uh kayaking or magnus
versus fabi
okay is that a wonder game yeah not not
xnotics this time
uh yeah maybe this is okay the standings
now crossbar i know
this is not sustainable uh nine ongoing
games okay so let's
start with this one huh okay
this is ended the game it ended
yes
refresh this page oh
and 30 30 30 seconds nominator is very
close
crossbar also zaro is one house so no
one without a loss so far
okay let's hear what's happening with my
sons filipino okay trinity half
ivano unesco okay some
quits okay which is
around three six seven two games or
there's two games to play right
okay all right copper versus who is
smartypants chess i i remember that
nickname
yes very strong versus
he's from uh
england or so yeah i think he's
okay nominator against my brother
yazarov
they played 22 games and the result is
fifteen percent for you zero
nepo doesn't stand a chance against
magnus no one stands a chance against
magnus
until they do your sister is here
the what ah valentina is here
they're they're on a vacation yeah she
sent me this uh
alpaca uh
check it out look at it
it's like a chess okay
um black and white yeah or
brown yeah
very cool
oh yeah i i don't see a world where that
can happen
pravish says how cool if chess authority
isolates players for one month
prohibiting any use of engine
uh before the world championship i i
don't think that's
that's possible anymore uh and i don't
know who would agree to that
like not not having a smartphone for a
month
okay alone time is my brother
yeah i don't think the players will be
able to use alpha zero for preparation
since um uh
i i don't think it's possible for the
moment they they both have
like extremely strong computers and uh
software
so i don't know i don't know if magnus
says access to cesai the
the norwegian supercomputer uh if he
does
that i guess it might be a bit of a
boost but
uh i mean russian if he doesn't have
resources
backing him then uh then i don't know
okay nominator is i think very
well doing he's the last are there still
games in progress
uh yes i mean watch yeah click
any filipino maybe yeah against
percoverto
they are friends oh i think
not after this game okay but
they will still be friends oh
that's that's a good pawn
yeah okay norwegians give magnus
everything he wants but
uh you know russia russia is vast
now you can make a mistake to take this
take what this pawn and then you have a
perpetual
i think or no you don't after
queen e1 d1 and and
queen covers this yes but you have to
take on
g2 or g7 if you take the pawn i thought
[Music]
this could be a mistake man now you can
take no you cannot
rg is exciting
but the queen can take
but he's very low on time i think
filipino will
win this year do i want nepal to win
no i i want uh i wanted there to be an
uh
an interesting event uh you know i i
wish it was like
16 extremely fighting games all 16 with
decisive result and then the match
ending in a draw and then we go into tie
breaks
uh better than maybe just 16 games drawn
and then we go into tie breaks and then
everything gets settled in rapid
but you know so it's very hard to
i very rarely have like favorites uh
when it comes to any
competition like even even when croatia
is playing in some sort of a tournament
and i'm croatian uh
i i mostly just enjoy watching no
like obviously if they win everyone here
will be happier and it's
i guess good for the economy but uh
that it gives me any special joy not not
really
no be careful
okay
how do i decide which comments to read
better brownish asks i i read the ones i
like
that that's how i that's how i do
everything in life
mostly okay let's
watch this all right so how many rounds
have we
got quit why ah he's not
in top three ah he lost the final game
yes
he's quitting next tournament all right
but the first three
places but he's qualified for the next
tournament isn't he streaming
yes he's streaming the top three are
automatically qualified for the next
final tournament okay okay they don't
have to play
uh these qualified tournaments okay this
is the
idea
okay for the first time i think this
tournament is very good how do i know
the ones that i like
i don't know sometimes i watch i watch
the
the chessboard for a long time and then
i miss most of the comments and then i
spot one
like this one it's it's not it's not
exact science
uh i try to you know scroll through them
with my eyes
uh but uh the this this time
when there are two of us the monitor is
a bit far so i can't really
read most of them uh but uh
i i do an okay job okay the last round
is no
no i've never been to the us
[Music]
andre
all right okay it's the last round at
the last round yes
all right this is all that's cool i
think by this fist turn
so it's the copper one unless
naminator or yes but book holds maybe
yeah okay we'll see okay let's look
coppa against
ruthie this is the final game for coppa
what what's what's uh em what's football
em
which someone says will croatia win the
football em i
am europa master chef europe no it's
europa minister
europe a european champion ah
i don't think so who who knows when when
when is the when are the games now in
such
two weeks i think we'll start maybe not
two weeks no
in month uh in six yes
in ten days maybe yeah okay now
the bars are opened again i think people
will will be watching them
but they were saying something like uh
that they have to prolong the the
working hours of the bar so people can
watch the game
until the end something like that or
maybe to continue celebrating
on the 11th of june someone says yes uh
so
yeah like in a week yes but i don't know
when croatia
is playing against england the first
game
we will see i hope they will qualify to
the quarter finals and then
later zaid khan congratulations man on
winning your
your championship nice nicely done
yes next sunday was england yes how do
you how do you
meistershaft europa masterchef deutsche
okay right that knight is coming to f4
no
i'm kronaldinho brother in law firm
against england what croatia against
england is
on the 13th of june yes nice that's a
a bit a bit ahead of my birthday
what's the eta of seeing it on stream oh
it's hard to say
she's still she's still in the hospital
she was born a bit uh
a bit early so she she has to gain some
weight
before they release her
copper is low on time
if he lose it will be interesting
oh yes this is now clear that
koppa is the winner of this tournament
congratulation
yes he took a queen yeah i think he just
came over
now completely
but you still know he's long time yeah
no he's just
gonna play uh rook f7 and bishop uh
somewhere okay anything
now it is not clear that he win this
game
you once went zero to 12 uh in a match
against josiah
what with which matthew elwood says he
he
he had a zero ah zero is very strong
yeah
happens
all the greatest chess players have no
hair
i i did not notice that
no it is not i'm very clear i'm pretty
sure everyone
in the top 100 has hair i could be wrong
like now i can't really and they have
like
a lot of hair he will play on time
against him
look at this now
coppa is in problems my friends
he's very yeah he thought okay hmm
oh okay i think he's now he's gonna now
he's gonna have to deliver a lot of
checks what
oh okay so he wants to win the pawn race
yeah but he's black winning no he's not
yeah black isn't winning this
that's a winning for white of course oh
man what no it is clear that
white is surprising
copper don't do that man okay maybe he
maybe
he cannot he cannot yeah but maybe he
messes up he cannot
miss this oh
oh brutality man okay it can still be a
draw
still maybe maybe maybe he gets a draw
no
i think not sure until the very end oh
man
it will be buchholz now
it will be scandinavian defense
yes i got mattered place
this line very often yeah but there is
chess in the olympic games
the the chesapeake but uh someone said
that
uh chess cannot be a real olympic sport
because you can't have
winter chess and summer chess okay and
that's like that's like the first
reasonable uh what is this
with seven points oh my goodness
uh because it kicks in
at the very end okay so who is still
bartow and playing party no it's oh it's
okay
okay let's let's watch as it's the last
game
the until we conclude the tournament
let's see
what's happening we'll see what is
happening yes and we will have
our first king
crisis in hungarian
so good to know what is it in hungarian
yeah
maybe one what
wow oh no okay maybe he wins yes of
course
good time he's no he blunders
nobody was the draw i think not
yeah he didn't have two squares i think
not
i'm talking about hillary on time yeah
nice nice draw
okay and now it is completely
pravier
three players with certain points yeah
very strong
with copper copper almost he won he won
he had
winning yeah okay uh yazarov
on the sixth place crossbay on the fifth
year okay copper and nominator
does have not played the tournaments
qualifying they are
and rudyard no no only the
first i including the winner the winner
is
he is waiting the challenger yeah and
coppa and dominator they play the final
battle the next time
and 24 new players come yeah then we
will have
26 players for the final tournament
and and will i organize more tournaments
that
30 players will be and after that we
will have the
winner from the final battle and this
winner will play against
ravier bach for the title yeah praveer
will become some messages from me and so
on and so on okay
so congratulations uh we're gonna accept
some challenges now if you guys uh if
you guys are interested
okay this is very cool tournament very
strong
you see three you cannot win all games
seven points and uh very very okay but
this is not the final battle the final
battle is when all the kings of the
castle
play for the final battle no no no the
king will play the match against one
player ah who wins the second
next final battle yes okay and they will
play 12 games
like a candidate so now now he's the
king of the castle and he's waiting for
he's waiting yes but can he also play he
can't play
but what kind of match will it be i say
it
12 games four bullet games one zero one
minute for the game then four games
three
minutes and four games three minutes
plus two seconds increments okay but
from from
higher to lower no blitz bullet ah
first ball and then after six six maybe
then
they will play two bullet games why like
that why not first slower
after that they played four last games
bullet games then played in
two more games bullet caps this is not
cool
for me and then you have
played for both games and ui and stuff
in this mood
but here after slow games you come to
bullet games
and you must change your mind ah so
what do you prefer slower to faster or
faster to slower
first fast and then just to slower oh i
i like first slow then fast
because in fast i can do a good result
against you
i'm weaker player and i can go to two
good results and then in the
slower you can beat me of course because
if you beat me
in the first slower games i can not
win you in the faster okay maybe
we will see we can change it of course
okay speaking of bullet okay since uh
we're okay we
can play triples yeah but uh
only non-rated games since uh we're
going to be using this account
okay okay yeah you can choose one i'm
gonna read some chat okay okay here
find girlfriend youtube okay
you're here and choose that one and you
will say what i play e4 or d4
uh i can see anything all right i'm
gonna
choose knight to f3 okay
very cool
very cool okay let's play d4
yeah no don't make it like a
ten minute or a five minute just like
three minutes or so
without increments increment is okay but
not five plus
yeah but then uh to do as many of them
as possible
okay now he will twist
let's go here
favorite eminem song oh i don't know
it's been for so long since i last heard
one
but uh probably something from from an
older album i i'd have to
i'd have to recollect my my memory a
little bit
too i know i'll i'll get back to you on
that one
okay what to do here i will attack here
all right we we can do a hand and brain
for next one
yes of course
what i will be
uh nope no i haven't been into death
metal all that much you can say i have
i do not have a favorite cardi b song
he's killing me thanks man thanks you
know this knight f3 move is
so weak if i ever consider moving to the
us i should go to texas
why is that
two nights against two bishops this is
not so cool for me i think
okay let's make stations bishops
strong i will maybe hear
with the queen later yes the bishops are
strong but
i don't give up i uh is it possible to
do hand and brain in bullet
yeah i mean of course it's possible but
yeah it will be very hard
not texas ah no state income tax
okay okay now here then texas will be
crawling with
uh you know everyone to block some
bishop
everyone will come to texas that's their
plan
where are my boys are they coming
no i think they they've switched to the
the fortnight
yes of course maybe
what's my viewers original demographic
spread now i haven't
checked it in a while but it's like uh
it's been like 30 percent united states
now it's i think it's a little bit less
maybe 25
us say then maybe 12 percent india
and then like canada germany i have to
play faster
or five percent uh england
um i posted one uh one
entire sheet uh on twitter uh i i could
do another one since it's been like a
year and a half
year and a half ago here everything but
north korea
okay let's check here
do i prefer electric vehicles or classic
internal combustion
cars uh i i prefer
electric vehicles although i do not own
one
i hope to own one uh you know sometimes
in the future
but i i'm i'm guessing everyone will at
some point
there are nice nice uh cafes
in belgium to play chess in i imagine
there are
i will take this with check and what is
this
david kota how many how many from
croatia are watching
the channel i i don't know the exact
number but i'm
pretty sure it's less than less than one
percent
of of all of them
you know but russia is small prepared to
other countries so that i i guess that's
that's fine
hey greetings greetings from netherlands
no i do not live in austria uh
it's not it's not not that far like a
like maybe a
four hour drive but you know it is kind
of on the other side
do i do i have an education no i am
completely uneducated
awesome video for the sicilian defense
such an er
such as an evans gamble oh my blunders i
could but
there are okay
there are many of them that good game
how to choose which one to show
okay let's play against us
now any
all right shall we do a hand and brain
one yes you can okay
let's go pawn okay come on d5
uh all right let's go let's go queen
oh no yes queen
okay this is this is winning already
knight
pawn
bishop what
what is that no it's okay it's okay this
is
completely winning for black
you're the third yeah queen queen okay
maybe porn nah queen
you don't want to trade no
i will attack you okay bear fair enough
oh th this will be all right knight
alright so queen
[Music]
very interesting yeah i don't like this
for white
at all alright so queen
uh yeah night
uh pawn probably king
yeah remove king yeah let's go pawn
bishop king free move
rook and now we can play yeah this
minority attack i think
yeah pawn horn
oh my god goodness white pawn
pawn no okay what is this
um pawn
it's very very interesting
[Music]
uh rook
c4 oh
all right this is my idea you
you told me rook i have this idea yeah
okay this was also good but we just uh
after that
we shouldn't but after that you cannot
take
because of this uh yeah
maybe push huh yeah i don't know you are
uh pawn pawn
pawn
who is the guest okay pawn horn
what to do with the pawn take it rook
all right we're doing good we're doing
this here we are battery time
yes of course rook rook
[Music]
king again
you don't like that no no
you aren't
okay so different plan pawn
and okay now pawn
oh yeah he attacked you yes i see
and now rook i could take you the pawn
maybe
okay he has to capture so we're okay
rook
rook
very nice all right rook
rock rock rock rock just rock
remove rook
okay king very cool
and now rook after he does whatever yeah
rook and then rook again
[Music]
he's going to attack it so rook again no
no king no king no it's clear that they
have to
yeah okay now king
or you don't want to go after those
pawns king
king rook
uh rook king
rook this is draw now king
bond
no cut off the king rook
okay but now we play now it's 10 seconds
no we had to cut off the king this is
also nice
rook and rook rook and rook this is the
rook
kinking yeah okay now with 10 seconds
you can finish you can finish whatever
yeah but before he got here okay but
this is a draw
yeah he's always here checking me yeah
but we we would be we would have more
chance of flagging him
okay all right this is this was a nice
one
i i always have a goatee it's just that
it's it's a bit more far away so so it's
hard to see
okay what's this pedro
very strong
okay uh
pender all right good luck pedro
okay what is now uh
night
night night
night all right night
oh no all right come on and now
night what oh you have two nights you
know that
but then
all right pawn thank you very much
all right let's let's win this night
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right completely new game yes let's
go for a pawn
yes thank you g6
all right we we can weaken that king
very good maybe we have to
castle ah okay
we are better with time remove bishop
night king
horsing around the the shrooms just
kicked in
all right so we we have a very nice
position yes completely
yeah faith yeah he does have a better
center but
uh that that's our plan we want to get
him okay king
king and rook or or only king
castles is the king's move is it not
okay
asked free move
pawn pawn yeah primo pawn
yeah clearly clearly white is
overextended
clearly we will lose this terribly but
then
no he will not no okay uh
what if he play okay go go for the night
look this night yeah okay now this is a
very very good night completely winning
okay
night i think he blundered night night
or maybe not well maybe yeah
okay king
[Music]
i was paying attention just capturing
the bishop but then
he might be having an attack we win a
piece but he might have an
okay here
you're you're moving all the wrong pawns
which pawn you
mean all right queen
all right next we have the the bishop
not there no it's
all right now pawn oh
he's spawn no he'll take this okay let's
go here
this spawn move i thought the g
pawn actually okay now now we capture he
could have captured on g6
nicely okay yeah also the same
okay so it works out i guess
you are undertone uh okay
i guess we go night
night night night
okay nice here we have to play faster
remove yeah pre-move rook if it if it
happens
if you take yes
okay no no no no let's go rook rook
yeah rook go rook osaki
here he can take it now we play queen
captors
but i could take here for free this
night
earlier okay i i i missed it
i was reading the chat
okay but this is good this is good
unless he plays g4 if he finds g4
we are doomed no nothing is happening we
have this all right queen
you sure well our queen is hanging so
yes
not here check yeah that's not that's
nothing yeah primo king h6
if it happens no but then then it's not
pre-moved
uh bishop
oh nice
okay i constantly think oh yeah will you
play and i will
say okay
that was a that was a nice one okay who
do we have
another three minutes i saw someone
here all right
it's a raider game we can only do
casualties okay
[Music]
all right it starts of course okay
pawn of course very nice pawn of course
all right okay paul born okay all right
cool
nice all right
uh pawn yes all right
pawn all right
pawn all right
all night
completely losing him he could take it
okay
of course no no but then we give up the
rook and
we we play we play this we are winning
this yes of course
yeah we don't mind
king gambit is this nothing no no this
is fine
okay now queen of course oh queen of
course
yes all right
[Music]
very nice uh bishop are you sure
you should please i thought maybe you
wanted to go king
and then we bring the rook in and he
could play knight e4 and you are
queen okay now we
remove yeah bishop
all right so now we kind of traded down
everything king
centralizing yes maybe
but it's fine we don't mind
we have these two strong pushers central
brook
[Music]
pre-move night
uh knight yes
all right well we couldn't play the
evidence again but since we
we we played the game okay now it is
completely
sure that we will play with tonight
okay very interesting
pawn
blender
he won't see it he won't see it okay
pawn
all right we have this we have this
we're down a pawn but
you you just say pawn yes of course this
is the only word i know
and now bishop now bishop
what do you want with the bishop
are you you're a madman
because of rook and you lose a bishop
that's why
you see king and if the bishop was there
you will lose
yeah yeah most most interesting
and now you will check my team oh come
on
oh no oh no
oh this is just this is just bad no you
can play
how could you do this
how could you do this
um
okay we can resign yes of course we will
not try to flag him
all right we can try another one
you now see how it's difficult yeah it's
it's it's uh
okay here a lot
tougher than than it seems all right
dark oh no that's a bullet we can't we i
don't think we'll be able to do it uh
let's play against someone and he must
play uh
this uh evan's gambit uh he must play no
we're not gonna we're not gonna
set it up excellent has to play now
everyone's coming okay
pawn okay okay but he will destroy
no okay now right yes
okay of course and bishop
no okay okay now you can take it of
course with
pawn okay and now you have to play
um knight
i don't think this is how you'd play it
i
like it to play this style after e5
you can play maybe d5
but you can only play pawn oh yes of
course yes
this is the gambit
and now knight
all right now we're now we're happy yes
of course
this is highton valley thanks man this
is the main line
i think
where are my sons uh don't you hear the
ball
ah they're playing with 12 okay pawn
only move yeah okay if it's an only move
you don't have to you don't have to wait
for it
bishop
all right king
all right we're almost fully operational
okay queen queen
are you sure
i thought i thought you'd wanted to go
knight first
uh bishop bishop all right
it's a very very brave
yes of course night night
yeah what can you do a bishop no and you
lose
you lose what tonight you you can't then
you pick up the queen
okay tonight you must have to play them
yeah but what what do you want to do
with the knight i don't get it
i don't know
i have an idiot
there is absolutely nothing with the
knight hall night move
there there are no knights move no
artists
93 i thought yes and then what
nothing happened
you had to play this okay i missed it
but okay we will we will win on time
it's it's no no
no this is not the way we will play no
we can't win on good moves we have to
win on time
okay queen all right
and
let's do it that's our that's our only
hope
it's not a very good one queen
all right
we're accomplishing little by little
okay now we win on time now we win on
time i think not
vodka and chess takes away the stress uh
uh
other than that rhyming uh yeah it's
probably true yeah
although i've never had vodka with chess
i've had
some clear axle you will lose some time
yeah
i've had other other strong liquor but
not
okay this is becoming very interesting
very interesting remove rook
remove queen oh no
yeah of course remove queen
ah he saw it no i can't play that
yes of course okay and then he takes
here okay
no problem nah we have to take he saw it
you you played that pawn move
there was no need to play that no play
along so now what we flagging
no no okay past pawn that's that's the
way to do it
nice nice nice
oh they're coming
who will play evan's gambit who will
play it first
that's in the chat please who is playing
evan's camp
and then we will play against him
but only evan's gambit
let's see who is playing the events
combat
in the chat nobody what are you doing
winning who we want okay it was the
first one we wanted for kiki
huh i will play better version of evan's
bruno partridge
there is no better version yes of course
all right bruno
bruno okay bruno we can play all right
but this will be one-on-one game not
uh not uh no no we play hand and brain
up again
yeah yeah okay e4 maybe he will play
to be fair no no it's uh
i think what is he doing uh he doesn't
want okay okay knight
he wants c3 yes of course grand prix no
but you have to say
okay pawn uh
okay i thought
i thought a4 not this okay
knight
is coming he's here
all right white pawn
timer bishop bishop all right let's go
bishop
it's a weird square for the bishop
okay we don't care if he pushes night
night very good
all right that's uh that's one beefy
night
what's it uh what's he doing now
[Music]
he's in the center all right
bishop this
let's go here this is my base of course
yeah just make this
this guy here weak yes playing against
him
all right we're doing well on time he's
yes the chess instructor okay okay
now uh queen
bishop bishop
yes very cool this is standard maneuver
in this line standard maneuver okay yes
yes
this is my line i like it to play okay
now
it is time to play the queen yes
this is very good all right you like it
though
ah i don't like our rook here yeah
different than that after
a4 ah okay okay that's the problem yeah
yeah
it seems yeah if a4 was in the game it'd
be
great played okay queen okay what do we
do with the queen
yes this is the best let's do this and
now how do we get our bishops into the
attack
no really yeah we'll see okay
okay night night
nice yes of course what you want that
yes of course
night okay and queen
queen queen queen queen queen queen
queen
uh yeah we have to go here yes there's
no there's no
better square although uh our pieces
are very much possible
you're very sneaky yeah he's 24. we have
okay okay we must draw us enough
meadow
okay pawn oh i like it
i like it
now bishop now we
come alive yes okay this is now easy
bishop
bishop bishop this
strange square for the bishop i thought
bishop f3 but okay
rook
bishop
why bishop
yes
[Music]
okay i i don't think he's passive
porn porn
oh this will not end well this will not
end
well remove queen uh bishop
bishop all right we'll play bishop
but now he takes takes and this okay no
problem
and kink of course
there is there is nothing better
okay oh that's disgusting bishop
that is disgusting
night night yes of course night
queen queen we're queen
are you insane i want to play ah
no i think we resign night then okay
you give checkmates here
yeah you cannot okay good game yeah this
was a good one but here
in the beginning after this e6
okay i always play yeah you have to play
a4
a4 yeah and you can okay
let's go here
here we play against
logo okay this is our friend from
castle uh-huh this is our right
pawn pawn okay pawn f4
[Music]
yes of course bruno you have to play
evans
that was our idea yeah but he played c5
yes and he totally blunders the evans
gambit
pawn pawn why that one
to castle uh okay
uh uh knight
okay we have to be quick because we
always uh
bishop remove bishop then pre-move king
then removes pawn and then pawn again
and then ending knight we don't care
about that pawn
okay now now we do pawn
okay i guess you could do that
pawn
uh pawn okay
nah uh rook
it's a very interesting okay i blended
this pawn
i have no idea night
was pretty move mm-hmm yeah yeah no
that's fine
free move yeah i don't think he will
trade he he won't
no he wants to attack maybe here with
the queen
no he can't to do that why not it's not
very good
okay this is good
and he's also attacking your rook yeah
porn
he can't attack our pawn like that
all right queen queen yeah queen queen
queen where to god with the queen here
maybe no offer queen trade ah
sorry now we're now we're screwed
queen
now there's not much we can do we have
to do that queen
id i don't see nothing yeah but he's in
center
yeah but okay
rook bishop
queen all the way
yeah i'm taking here yeah now now we
don't care
okay uh he wants to play bishop c5 so
we're gonna play pawn no rook rook where
huh uh rook
huh okay now he's probably gonna attack
us with the queen something like queen
h5 and then what do we do
and now uh now
queen
oh this is fine
win
yeah obviously
uh you can't move that rook
so now we either win or draw
we will see unless he plays d3 with
check
he might play d3 with the discovery i
have seen better players than in
canadian in my life
surely
ah okay so bishop we can play gm now
bishop
bishop yeah bishop and then bishop of
course
and then bishop and then bishop
okay maybe here with queens and you know
uh maybe okay if you want we can try
okay i i i
i was happy with the draw but you can
you can try yeah
i didn't even consider i forgot we have
the rook on a1
yeah with two rooks yeah okay
so rook
okay now pawn we don't want to open up
this
yeah rook
are you give up the bishop
rook
[Music]
go after him sure no no
rook just uh now you play
we having rook yeah okay you can win
this now
of course just pre-move you have 16
seconds
very good very good
all right grab it now you do whatever
okay we're better on time yeah it's a
good thing you you decided to play but
you should move faster just move the
rope move the rook on the light squares
oh you want to checkmate him
oh what is this why why did you play
like this i don't know i don't
just move the rook and anyway okay okay
okay yeah okay
uh but okay this is my friend that's
what you get for not accepting the draw
but okay
we will see what is he doing okay
because he's eight years old and
he will have changed it's very strong
huh yes
i think if he's here oh
this is not what he has done
um
all right i'm ivano this is very very
very interesting
why did you play like this i mean it's
uh what is the idea here
it's a fair question yes of course
okay now he's gonna have an excellent
attack in the center
i actually hate playing this with black
with white
but okay now i don't know why not
playing
maybe f6 is his idea okay but still
you can still play yes okay okay now i
i think he just well he he made it a lot
easier for me
okay now he will play five yeah
all right we'll see maybe this is the
modern theory
maybe the one i'm not i'm unfamiliar
with
could very well be no c5 yes of course
you see very good very good
okay
[Music]
the bishop how will this bishop play
okay that's uh interesting
do i care about this one not really
he can have the pawn the bishop is doing
nothing
yeah and it's still undeveloped so
i don't know
how strong is your friend again oh
extremely strong
extremely all right so let's do this
because we we want to exploit his rooks
still being disconnected
um no it is now it's very interesting
i think you have some
[Music]
yes this awesome idea
oh i just blundered the knight first
character
but he he forgot about it too yes okay
all right
all right be careful no no no i will
oh that okay it's a very very
interesting
tempo yeah because i would have
sacrificed the two knights here most
likely
you can do it
he will probably give it up no no but if
you can
bishop his boss completely should be
saying maybe
yeah bishop d7 but yeah he'll do it
he'll do it yeah
of course he will very good very good
okay now let's
let's try and activate this queen uh
because
unless he can develop we're we're okay
if he can okay now
now we're giving up the knight as well
he has to give this knight now for the
pawn this is
the only thing he wants he wants it all
you know he wants it all it is very
difficult to play
against this pawn yeah okay the the
bishop can
be developed i i guess
but no did he leave yes ivana will be
future gm surely yeah i i think he left
no no he's thinking oh okay okay
ah okay so now i i i was hoping for this
but
i guess also also just
this is fine
yeah now this and that's it
yeah good stuff
nice of course good stuff he must
give yeah and then play it's a rook okay
with the rook yeah he can still play
and very druze
yeah most definitely
rook i'm not rook
okay now it's
be careful
knight d1 is interesting yes
uh it's very interesting take your pawn
take a pawn here for free
yes of course yeah oh that's uh
no it's not no it's not but let's just
lock this guy
in okay he's uh
also very long time so that's also give
him 50 seconds
give him 15 seconds give him seconds
okay we give him seconds
uh all right so we don't care about this
pawn we're gonna take the
the knight yes of course what did his
draw
nah yes of course when he takes
uh no he could take
no he can't it's a
it's look and now it is draw
no it's not you cannot go through this
yes i can
oh uh i will flag him i haven't seen
this
i have queen what is this theoretical
draw
no no look at this no not look at this
no not but he could fall
oh no
all right do we offer a draw no no no
no okay okay good one but okay he played
very good yeah uh he probably could have
drawn that but
okay let's see who is also here
that knight's the d1 move was very very
sneaky yes you could take
the phone this was his yeah
who is the next
maybe some strong who will who will
accept the evidence gambit i
i hope everyone will play the talent
talent very talents
google talent he will play
talent to ireland
no there is no play the talent the
talent
the talent i have to open challenges
okay here yeah
but click where yeah
here is here's okay he played three plus
okay the what chips two no no no no
increment
no increments okay track no traffic
increment is bad for
for for streaming i'll pick anyone you
don't have to
pick from the chat because all of these
people are here for a very long time
[Music]
okay
robin joseph doing doing great man
should i play on
no no oh yeah okay you'll play one i'm
gonna read the chat a little okay
i will play this line can you flag
someone during a draw offer of course
i i've heard there's even a famous game
that uh
happened where one player was trying to
make a draw offer and the other one
proceeded with flagging
it is 1 30 in india go sleeping
[Music]
all right i think you can pull this one
off whoops
he's not uh exclusively from the bar
but we have we have met uh many a time
in the bar yeah
you have a test uh 8 a.m tomorrow
wha what kind of a test do you have on
sunday a covet test
now that's a that's an actual question
why is the quality so bad do you mean
the quality of the stream or the
quality of chess but
or maybe something kind of
okay take it this click here
uh move camera so we can see more of
gordon i i'm trying to but goran
constantly keeps moving
he's like uh like a hyena
can i take here
what is the yellow gear for oh that
that's not mine that's
yellow and seal and uh uh use that uh
for
exercising purposes
for this yeah a pawn is a pawn no
he can take with the bishop yeah but if
he doesn't and then here
take this pause are you drunk gordon
no no i i have not had a single beer i
don't
drink yeah in my life only when i'm with
our gods
but it's very very hot here so okay some
guys are coming now who are the guys
why are you coming right now yeah evil
evil the
legend where are you the whole time
what are you doing down there
you're playing blasphemy very good yes
i made
[Music]
[Music]
yeah she's in a hospital resting she had
quite uh
quite a task okay and i'm
totally losing
he didn't like it he doesn't see it
why are you why are you playing so bad i
don't know
i'm reading the chat you're you're
playing so
bad with what is this he sacrificed the
queen
unbelievable nikki tamalik
okay here
what are typing
no a rapid is the only time for me i
don't enjoy playing
but i i enjoy watching some chat here's
humanize
yeah if you want to know how elena is
doing it you can ask her
she is in the chat
what i'm doing
one sacrifice
all right is the
i i i think you have this i think you
have this
but you can still you can still make it
a draw
do i like paul morphy yeah yeah he's an
okay dude loving
loving loving all the uh get well
yelling messages in the chat
who is helena it doesn't matter
just say hello just say
have a good one and and rest rest plenty
what do you mean don't only teach the
evans
can i do it
okay this is enough all right very nice
i thought he played our tournament no no
no no
all right so that's uh that's it for
this uh stream guys uh
so congratulations to everyone who
played in the tournament who won the
tournament
and if you uh wanna uh be included in
everything that happens in future
uh king of the arena tournaments uh make
sure to
uh to join the argo matas castle group
only chess and also
uh my own group that's uh what's what's
the name of my group
team what's the name of my team agatha
mata steam yeah okay
so you can join aganator's team in
almatraz castle and you will be
included in all of uh future tournaments
but
we're gonna post post them here and
there you know and on
twitter on facebook i think gordon even
puts it on
instagram and uh i'm gonna mention it
from time to time
in a video here and there so you guys
know know what's happening but yeah
congratulations to the winners and uh
yeah
that's it thanks gordon for for joining
me on this uh
thank you epic adventure and we even
we even won some games yes of course
thank you for watching and see you soon
guys and uh
[ __ ]